voilà philo tout cela hier
[Musique]
propage
à temps
à 17 ans
b
[Musique]
vous avez appris vous êtes enceinte
comment vous avez là c'est un chèque
c'est pas rien c'est pas rien avez vous
choisi de 35 mademoiselle non ce que
votre copain a choisi d'être papa
maintenant
non vous n'êtes pas la première à qui ce
genre de show de l'incident dans la vie
d'une femme arrive ça peut arriver ya
beaucoup de personnes et c'est arrivé à
beaucoup de personnes
[Musique]
chaque femme en france qu'elle soit
majeure ou mineure a le droit d'avoir
recours à une ivg quand elles ne
souhaitent pas maintenir une grossesse
qui est ton qui est engagée une femme ne
choisit peut-être pas toujours d'être
enceinte
il suffit d'un défaut de contraception
d'un accident dans sa contraception pour
plusieurs raisons ça peut être un oubli
tout simplement on a oublié sa pilule un
soir eh ben on manque de bol c'est tombé
on a mis un préservatif mais
préservatifs à craquer ou alors chez
certaines femmes qui peuvent être sous
l'emprise d'un compagnon qui refuse
toute contraception
donc elle ne peut pas se protéger ne se
sentent pas en altitude de le faire donc
ne va pas se protéger et donc court le
risque d'une grossesse non désirée
c'est pour ça que le recours à l'usagé
c'est pour toute femme qu'elle demande
[Musique]
que souhaitez-vous faire avez vous déjà
envisagé un petit peu ce cas de figure
que et si un jour j'étais enceinte
qu'est ce que je ferai oui je pense les
vg mais c'est dur de prendre une
décision pareille vous vous sentez
comment vous si vous avez des sentiments
de culpabilité vous avez ce genre de
choses qui vous pèse
un peu oui et que va dire la famille et
comment va gérer ça la question
[Musique]
un entretien psychosocial créé ivg est
un entretien qui est fortement conseillé
à toute femme qui est obligatoire pour
les mineurs et qui se passe ou dans le
cadre du conseil conjugal et familial ou
par une sage-femme et éventuellement
aussi par une assistante sociale
cet entretien est obligatoire pour les
mineurs est donc conseillé aux majeurs
tout simplement pour que ces femmes
puissent mettre des mots sur ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qu'elles ressentent et
ça permet aussi de faire le point avec
ou la sage-femme ou la conseillère
conjugale de caisse qui a fonctionné
pendant sa contraception qu'est-ce qui
n'a pas fonctionné parce que des fois il
suffit d'un petit incident tout bête et
un accident de vie c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle qui fait que voilà cette dame
où cette jeune femme va se retrouver
dans une situation qu'elle n'a pas voulu
mais elle a des émotions exprimées et
elle a des questions à poser
qu'est ce qui va se passer ou est-ce que
ça va se passer quand ça va se passer
etc etc
et puis là près ces espaces d'entretien
psycho sociaux servent à ça
[Musique]
ce qui se passe après un entretien avec
nous on conseil conjugal ou sage-femme
donc c'est que cette jeune femme va être
orienté ensuite vers un médecin ou
sage-femme habilités ou hospitaliers en
fonction de son désir c'est à elle de
choisir ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
nos préalable au centre de planification
le médecin va lui déjà lui faire une une
prescription médicale pour avoir une
échographie de contrôle pour dater ou
est ce qu'elle en est tout simplement et
on va aussi lui prescrire des bilans
sanguins de façon à mesurer le taux de
betao south qu'elle en est exactement
dans cette grossesse et en fonction de
ce terme est bien pareil elle aura le
choix entre deux méthodes donc la
méthode médicamenteuse ou la méthode par
aspiration pareil le choix de cette
méthode
c'est elle qui le garde mais il est vrai
que c'est conditionné aussi par le
résultat de ces qte cette échographie
ici le monde est trop avancé dans cette
grossesse il n'y a qu'une seule méthode
utilisée c'est la méthode chirurgicale
mais on ne peut pas aller au delà de 14
semaines mais un délai légal est ce que
tu en penses
[Musique]
le recours à une ivg est un droit
fondamental qui est ouvert aux majeurs
et aux mineurs en france et comme vous
êtes mineur tout peut se passer dans le
cadre de l'anonymat donc on est pas on
n'est pas obligés d'informer qui que ce
soit mais maintenant on vous vous il va
falloir que vous soyez accompagnés d'un
majeur si vous prenez cette élection
pourquoi pas un ou deux parents est ce
que c'est quelque chose que vous pouvez
aborder avec maman ou papa
elles jettent ou pas du tout non qu'est
ce qui pourrait se passer parce que dans
le cadre légal il faut vous soyez
accompagné par un majeur n'est pas alors
ça peut être un parent ça peut être un
ami quelqu'un confiance
cet entretien se passe dans un cadre un
peu comme ce qui est dans mon bureau on
l'accueille avec bienveillance dont
jugement nous ne sommes absolument pas
là pour lui dire que ce qui se fait le
bien ou le pas bien entre guillemets de
ce qui s'est passé c'est sa volonté
c'est son choix elle est reçue dans le
respect elle reçut dans surtout dans la
plus grande confidentialité post
free propose
m
b
[Musique]